Andrew Tay has been arrested but the  official narrative makes no sense they  say he got arrested for human  trafficking and organized crime but Tate  is no dum-dum why would he spend all  this effort to become famous why would  he make himself this much of a Target  why would he openly brag that he lives  in Romania if he's operating a human  trafficking ring if you were operating a  human trafficking ring would you spend  your time calling out governments and  powerful people on top of that Tate has  a lot of status men with a lot of status  don't have to resort to holding women  against their will the women come on  their own free will which is why